on sait maintenant pour faire le
making-of escales de nérac bonsoir au
début qu'il est actuellement beaucoup
parler d'un film de copains certes des
gens qui ne se connaissaient pas mais
les indications de suite quelque chose
de une jauge niveau kad merad
merci linh-dan pham merci beaucoup voilà
notre émission sur le making-of touche à
sa fin
ces types et joie de vivre et bonne
humeur et comme vous le constatez les
gens sont très ravis voir plusieurs fois
et actions
allez
c'est alors attendez c'est bon c'est bon
là c'est bon c'est bon
en fait cela allait aller et je suis pas
gros hockey et j'attends et je suis pas
mort c'est dégueulasse attend avait bien
le haut
s'il vous plaît aucune chance coran riva